Hello. Connected Data World
twenty twenty one.
My name is Peter Kaloroumakis,
and I'm happy to
get to present
the defend project
to you today.
A little background on me.
I work for, MITRE
Corporation.
We're based in
the United States,
and we focus on,
research and
development problems
for our sponsors, primarily,
the government.
Before I came to MITRE,
I worked in commercial product
development, and I,
designed and built,
malware detection products,
for network
security purposes.
So today, I'm gonna give you,
an overview of sort
of the motivation
behind this project,
what problems we were
trying to solve.
I'll talk about,
what we built,
a little bit on
how we build it,
and then also talk about how
some people are
using it to help
better organize
their cybersecurity
defenses. So let's
get started.
So first, I wanna get
into the motivation
for this project.
And before I start
talking about defend,
one of the things I have to
orient you to is
another MITRE project.
It's called MITRE ATT and CK.
MITRE ATT and CK
was a is is a very
popular framework
for characterizing,
what specific things,
cybersecurity adversaries are
doing when they break
into a network.
This model was built by MITRE
over a number of years and
publicly released,
and it's really
taken the industry
by storm.
And the result effect is that
when when
cybersecurity products
are able to, detect
something bad,
they characterize it using
terminology from
this MITRE ATT
and CK project.
So, once that was, deployed,
sort of it got out there,
it became very successful,
a sort of natural
question arose,
which is sort of,
could you describe what
cybersecurity defenders do and
as much fidelity as we,
describe the cyber
the attackers?
So we basically proposed this
project to help
organize the defensive
space the same way that,
MITRE had organized,
the offensive space.
So this defensive
space is huge.
And if you think
about it in two
main buckets, first,
sort of technical policies.
There are thousands of these
technical policies
which describe
how cybersecurity protections
can be applied to IT
infrastructures.
And, you know,
there's a lot of
material there.
The top image at the right is
sort of documents
that describe
how to do this grouped
by the general,
sort of domain.
And in each of
those documents,
there might be hundreds of
recommendations
or requirements
that people have
to implement.
The other big component
of this space,
the other major bucket is,
cybersecurity vendors.
So
the cybersecurity marketplace
is pretty large.
It's a pretty big market.
There are thousands
of these vendors.
Some of these vendors have
multiple products,
and some of those products,
performed dozens of
discrete functions.
So this really
quickly gets into,
a high dimensional
space that's
difficult to
manage if you're,
you know, organizing your your
defenses and you have to keep
track of all of
this information.
So in order to address all of
this complexity,
we wanted to build
a conceptual
model to help
organize this space.
There's a lot of
challenges with
trying to do this,
particularly because it's such
a complex and nuanced space.
One of
the challenges specifically
with cybersecurity
is the amount
of complexity and
nuance in all
the terminology that's used.
And one of the things we asked
ourselves was, how do we know
if we were successful
in building
a useful model?
We felt like if we could use
the same model for multiple
target audiences,
that would give us
some indication
that we hit that
abstraction or
semantic sweet spot,
if you will.
So imagine three
sort of target
audiences. First,
cybersecurity
architects who are
managing these
complex portfolios.
They really have to understand
what specific functions
all of these,
products and offerings they're
purchasing, do in
great detail.
Another target
audience is what
we call adversary emulation,
where they're doing a pen test
on a system, and they have to
really understand how these
things work in order
to have a successful
, useful pen test.
Imagine a third
audience for this.
Let's say
a cybersecurity investor
who's trying to decide whether
or not they should
invest in a product.
They have to understand what
problem is being solved,
has that been solved before,
and is this being
done in a new
and novel way. Right?
So we felt like if we could
address these
multiple audiences,
that would give us
some indication
we were on the right track.
So we set about
building this,
and three years,
in the in the making
with a very
small team, we
put together what
you see today. We
call it the defend
knowledge graph.
You can go to defend dot mitre
dot org to browse the graph,
and it renders
portions of the,
graph in the underlying model
for people to
start to use it.
It's very early
stage, and there's,
some rough edges,
but we felt like it
was at the point
where it made sense to open it
up for collaboration.
We built the graph by,
analyzing lots of open source
materials that explain how
cybersecurity
technologies work
in detail. This information is
very difficult to get,
but we found
a dataset that was
sort of hiding
in plain sight.
And it didn't look like anyone
else had
actually systematically
analyzed this corpus before.
And these were,
patents that were
filed by these
cybersecurity
vendors that explain
how their product
works or what
specific problem it's
going to solve.
There's a lot of diversity in
the patent corpus.
And for us, the challenge was
how do you take a twenty or
thirty page document and turn
it into two, three,
or four words that
really crisply
explain what it's doing.
So we developed a methodology
which lets us
systematically do that,
and that's part
of how we built
the the overall model.
The picture you see at the top
left is the most prominent
taxonomy inside of defend.
Those are the defensive
countermeasures,
of course, arranged
by, type hierarchy.
And what we did was we render
it as sort of
a tabular view in
order to get folks interested
in the content that's embedded
in the graph.
We also want
people to use this
graph to do more
sophisticated modeling,
and we built it using standard
ontology tools in
order to support
those use cases.
One obvious first
use case is,
okay. Now that I've got these
defensive countermeasures
identified,
what offensive techniques are
are those going to address?
So you see this
picture of defend
connected to attack,
with these red lines.
And then you see this call out
in the middle here with this
idea that we call
digital artifacts.
So instead of just directly
relating
the defensive techniques
to the offensive techniques,
we do it through inference and
reasoning through
this intermediate
model. And I'm
gonna talk about
that in much more detail on
the next slide here.
So what you're
gonna see is this
sort of cartoon view blown up
with specific
examples of the types
of information,
we're tracking.
So, the same view,
you've got attack
on the left,
defend on the right.
And in the middle,
you see what we
call the digital
artifact ontology.
So this is describing
all the sort
of basic computer
science concepts,
that someone taking computer
science one zero one might be
learning about.
And, surprisingly,
we didn't find a model
that existed,
that met our needs to for
cybersecurity purposes.
So we ended up having to take
a lot of basic
computer science
terminology and make it a bit
more specific,
because at the end
of the day,
a lot of times,
the attackers are abusing
functionality in
the computer,
and we end up
needing to be more
precise about what specific
functionality they're
manipulating.
So you see on the left,
a few of these
offensive techniques,
exploitation techniques,
and then another exploitation
technique called,
process injection.
And and then on the right,
you've got this defensive
technique process code segment
verification.
And both of these
are mapped to
this intermediate
concept called a process
code segment.
And the relationship
on the offensive
side is that these techniques
are modifying this concept,
and then on
the defensive side,
you're verifying
this concept.
You can see that
a process code
segment is a type
of code segment,
which is a digital artifact.
And then you see some object
property relationships.
For example, a process running
on your computer
contains process
code segments. The process
originated from an executable
binary file,
that contains code segments.
And when the process
is running
on your system,
it loads those executable,
parts of the file into memory
and then executes those.
And then sometimes those are
the parts that attackers will
overwrite with code
that you don't want.
So if you wanna
check the integrity
of your processes in
their memory space,
you might try to
verify process
code segments. So once we have
those definitions defined,
we can then infer
that this one
defensive technique
might detect
this particular
offensive technique,
without needing to directly
declare that.
And because of the amount of
information we're
dealing with,
this ends up being
a much more scalable,
manageable approach that lets
you reason about,
the the the whole graph,
rather than trying to manually
go through and
map everything,
accordingly. So
this is sort of,
an advancement in the state of
the art for us, which is,
to to do these sorts of things
by inference
instead of manually
mapping things
one to another.
So next,
I'm gonna show you what this
information looks
like in the actual
tool. So if you
go to defend at
mitre dot org,
you can, load up,
the home page, and you'll see
this countermeasure technique
taxonomy that that
you see here.
Across the top,
we have what we call
defensive tactics.
Those are sort
of the maneuvers
that a defender can perform in
response to
adversary activity.
And then beneath that are what
we call defensive
techniques or
countermeasure techniques.
These are,
the the highest order ones at
the at the second
level and then,
more specific types
of of the technique
as you go down the column.
So user behavior analysis has
more specific types of user
behavior analysis,
and process analysis has more
specific types of
process analysis.
One of which is is the example
I gave in the slide,
process code segment
verification.
Right? And this number
we're showing,
we found six public references
that indicate there
are technologies
that do this. So
we believe it's
worth including into,
the knowledge base.
So if I click this, you get,
what we call the knowledge
base article.
This is all encoded,
in the ontology.
And there you have a crisp
definition of of
this concept.
We wanna be able
to ask a vendor,
do you do this? Yes or no?
You get an explanation of how
this works that's developed by
reading all of the references
at the bottom of this page,
and and then our
subject matter
experts basically
summarize those.
And they also add a a section
on consideration.
So, in this case,
with this technique,
they're talking
about potential
false positives and
false negatives.
Then, once we
specify what this
technique is doing to what
specific digital artifact,
we can then infer
what are the related
offensive techniques that we
might care about.
Now this,
this table down
here is sort of
a a miniature, attack table.
So if you go to
attack dot mitre
dot org, you'll see
the full table,
which has, around five hundred
of these techniques.
In this case, we're selecting
only the relevant ones
for the user to,
review and determine, okay.
Will this defensive
technique,
protect me against,
these offensive techniques?
And then
the semantic relationships
go both ways. So some of how
we're doing the inference,
takes into account,
hierarchy and,
the type hierarchy
within the the
artifact definition.
So if a higher
order concept is
interacting with
a digital artifact,
then that flows
down to the lower
order concepts as well.
So in this case,
we're showing if if
you hover here,
you can see the relationships
on the offensive side.
Process hollowing is modifying
a process code segment,
but in this case,
credential API hooking might
modify or may modify a process
code segment.
So a lot of times
in cybersecurity,
you're dealing
with maybes, and,
we've at least come
up with a systematic
way to describe those sorts of
scenarios. And then down here
is the references we used to
develop this article,
and you can go click those and
see the in this case,
this is a particular
patent that
it links to, and you can see,
what we read to
basically develop
this article. Right?
There's a number
of other things
you can do with
the user interface.
You can look up topics by
offensive technique
or defensive
technique with these
two search boxes.
So if I wanna look
up a defensive
technique like
dynamic analysis,
I can do that here,
and that'll take
me to that page.
Or I can look up the offensive
technique. Let's say I wanna
look up rootkit.
What do what do attackers do
when they install a rootkit?
Well, if you look
at this graph,
we sort of codify that,
and the offensive technique is
in the middle.
Some inferred
defensive techniques
are on the left,
and then the relevant digital
artifacts are on
the right here.
And we're showing that this
offensive technique
might modify
kernel modules,
shared library files,
the kernel itself,
or firmware on the system.
So, then we infer
because these
defensive artifacts
are interacting
with those that
they might detect
it or you could deceive this
offensive technique
or you might
harden against this
offensive technique.
Right? And then you can click
on any of these boxes and get
definitions. So what is a what
is firmware in defend?
Well, if you click that,
it takes you to this page,
which has a definition and
additional relationships.
In this case, it's showing you
firmware verification, might,
verify firmware.
And then there's,
some specific
offensive techniques
that attackers do to
modify firmware.
And in this case,
we're showing
different types.
So you see, there's firmware,
but then there's specifically
system firmware as well.
So some offensive techniques
modify your system firmware,
and some of them
might modify,
peripheral firmware,
for example.
So that's a quick spin through
the user interface.
So I wanna talk a little bit
about how we name
these things.
Basically, the methodology I
talked about earlier was is
pretty straightforward,
but it,
kind of embarrassingly took us
a long time to
figure this out.
We simply describe
it along two
dimensions of specificity,
the noun and the the verb.
So we we say
the the digital artifact,
the noun, or
defensive action,
the verb. So,
there's three examples here.
The least specific
example would
be segment analysis.
And then as you move
up to the right,
we get,
the most specific process code
segment verification,
the example I gave earlier.
Verification in this case here
is we're saying is
a more specific
type of analysis.
And the reason we took this
approach was we
wanted multiple
teams within
an organization to
be able to use
the same, framework.
If you have someone working in
acquisitions,
they may not care
too much about the specific
the most detailed
example of, let's say,
file analysis. They just wanna
track whether or not they have
a file analysis capability or
a process analysis
capability.
But if you have
a practitioner,
they might want to know about
all the different
ways you could
do file analysis or
process analysis.
And by having that
taxonomical approach,
it lets us address
both technical
and nontechnical
users and then
capture metrics
accordingly with
the same language
framework. Right?
So I'll talk a little bit here
about how people
are using defend
to answer questions
about their
cybersecurity posture.
So in this example,
we took a specific threat.
It was, identified
in this threat
report. You can see
the link there.
And then they wanted to know,
would we have had
any protections
against this
threat given these
three specific
products that we
purchased? So what we did was
we took the threat report,
and it was mapped to MITRE ATT
and CK in terms
of the offensive
techniques that
the adversary was using.
So you can see in this attack
matrix view on the left,
for initial access,
they executed a supply
chain compromise.
For persistence,
they installed
a scheduled task
job and a boot auto start
execution script.
And then what we
did was we took
the defensive
products and broke
them down using defend and
identified what
they were doing.
So of these three products,
they were doing some hardening
techniques, some
detection techniques,
and some isolation
techniques.
And then But
they were not part of these
three products' capabilities,
so that's marked as
red and purple.
And then we step
through the rest
of the attack,
and we had some
capability in this area.
So that was marked amber and
then red in this other area.
So the result was that you get
these sort of higher level
insights about,
where you might
wanna make your
investments. You might wanna,
in this case, make
your investments
more in application
hardening,
platform hardening,
and operating
system monitoring
because you don't
have anything there.
Now they did have some
capability here,
but here's a case where,
everybody's sort
of different.
If you're in a well resourced
environment and you wanna add
diversity and depth
to your defenses,
you might actually
make additional
investments in this area,
to add diversity
to your defenses,
or double up on certain types
of analytics, for example.
But if you're in a resource
constrained environment,
you might,
take some of
the investment you
put in this area
and put it into
the areas where you
had no capability.
So the idea is that depending
on what question you're trying
to answer, you
can use the same
framework to tell
the story about,
what direction you think your
organization should go.
So finally, I'll
leave you with this.
This is a project that we open
source to collaborate
with the industry
on. So I'll close out with,
how to get involved
with the project
if you're interested in it.
You can ask vendors,
what defend techniques they
support when you're
making an acquisition
in this space.
And by thinking in terms of
digital artifacts and
defensive verbs,
you can start to
answer this question.
With this specific
defend technique,
we can detect these
attack techniques.
And then that tells the whole
story about what
specific function
in your enterprise is is is
dealing with
a particular threat.
Right? The knowledge
base, again,
is available at
defend dot mitre
dot org, and we've published
the ontology on
that page as well.
And it's, it's
an OWL two format,
and people can download it and
extend it as they see fit.
And we're looking
for contributions.
So if folks wanna add to it,
they can send us an email at
defend at mitre dot org,
and we'll be very
happy to engage
with you.
So thank you for
the opportunity
to speak here to
you all, and,
I look forward to
your questions.